foreign
so we built a virus resistant organism
why
it's not about disease or not directly
it's about building the clean factories
of the future
let me explain by taking a big step back
all life runs on DNA
DNA codes for proteins and proteins run
life
DNA is composed of four bases
a t g and C
and Triplets of these bases known as
codons encode each of the amino acid
building blocks in proteins
the genetic code is a rule book that
defines which codon encodes which amino
acid
so for example
the triplet codon TCG encodes the amino
acid serine
and the Order of triplet codons in DNA
encodes the order of amino acid building
blocks in a protein
there are 64 triplet codons in DNA and
just 20 common amino acids
and this means that most amino acids are
encoded by more than one triplet codon
so for example the amino acid serine is
encoded by six different triplet codons
and triplet codons that encode the same
amino acid are defined as synonymous
codons
the DNA code used for life is near
Universal
all forms of life and viruses use
essentially the same genetic code
and that's a trait that we can exploit
here's what we did
we asked whether life needs multiple
synonymous codons to encode a single
amino acid
for example does life need six different
codons which all code for the amino acid
serine
we took the four million character DNA
of E coli its genome and completely
rewrote the code of this microbe in a
very specific way
by replacing targeted codons in its
genome with synonymous codons that
encode the same amino acid
so for example
we replaced the TCG and TCA codons which
encode the amino acid serine
with AGT and AGC codons which also
encode the amino acid serine
by doing this across the whole 4 million
based genome we completely removed the
targeted codons from the genetic code of
E coli
overall we compress the genetic code
from using 64 codons to using 61 codons
how did we do it
we first took the 4 million character
code in a computer
and use the find and replace operation
to replace targeted codons with their
synonyms
this created our new genome design
which contained more than 18 000 changes
with respect to the original genome
we then asked whether we could build an
organism that runs on our synthetic
genome design
we built the synthetic genome starting
from short pieces of DNA
these were made by chemistry in a test
tube something that would have been
prohibitively expensive to do on this
scale just a decade or two ago
we then assembled these short pieces of
DNA into longer stretches of DNA which
we then used to step-by-step replace all
four million bases of the E coli genome
this created the largest synthetic
genome ever made
and the resulting cell was alive
think about that we streamlined the
genetic code
and yet the cell lived we can create
life with a compressed genetic code
now because our organism with a
compressed genetic code doesn't use all
64 triplet codons to make proteins
we could remove some of the Machinery
from the cell that normally reads the
near universal genetic code
specifically we could remove components
of the translational Machinery specific
trnas that normally read the codons that
we've removed from the genome
now the key Point here is that we've
created a cell that no longer reads all
the codons in the near universal genetic
code
now viruses infect cells
these might be the cells of our bodies
or single cell microbes like E coli
they commonly have their own DNA which
uses the near universal genetic code to
encode the proteins necessary to make
copies of the virus
but viruses don't have the Machinery to
read the genetic code in their DNA and
instead they rely on the host cell the
Machinery of the host cell to read the
genetic code in their DNA and make
copies of the virus
it's these copies of the virus that go
on to infect other cells and this is how
viruses spread
but viruses are unable to make copies of
themselves in our new organism because
our new organism doesn't have the
Machinery to read all the codons in the
DNA of the virus the code in the DNA
used in the virus and the host cells
Machinery to read that code are
incompatible
therefore the virus doesn't spread in
the new organism and the new organism is
resistant to viruses
in fact we showed that our new organism
was resistant to a wide range of viruses
suggesting that rewriting the genetic
code provides a route to creating
broadly virus resistant life
by extending the approaches we've
developed to other organisms it may be
possible to create virus resistant crops
and animals with important applications
in agriculture and Beyond
but our advances also provide a
foundation for turning cells into the
clean factories of the future
how
so to explain let me take another step
back to how organisms read the genetic
code to make proteins
recall that the order of triplet codons
in DNA encodes the order of amino acid
building blocks in a protein
and it's the translational Machinery of
cells that reads the triplet codons and
builds the corresponding sequence of
amino acids
the translational Machinery of natural
cells including ribosomes Amino acel
TRNA synthetase enzymes and trnas is a
unique and special system for making
proteins in which the 20 common amino
acids are strung together in a chain
now proteins are amazing
but they're just one example from a vast
class of molecules known as polymers
which includes Plastics materials and
drugs
and a polymer or a linear polymer is
really any molecule in which simpler
chemical building blocks are strung
together in a chain
we wanted to unlock the potential of the
translational machinery for making
Plastics materials and drugs
that simply can't be made in any other
way
or that could be made more cleanly and
efficiently using engineered versions of
the cell's translational machinery
the building blocks for these polymers
go well beyond the 20 common amino acids
used to make proteins
it's been impossible to unlock the
potential of the translational machinery
for making Plastics materials and drugs
for two reasons
first
all 64 triplet codons in natural cells
are used for making natural proteins and
there are simply no codons available to
encode the synthesis of new polymers
second the natural translational
Machinery specifically uses natural
amino acids and simply can't use the
chemical building blocks required to
make new polymers
however
are virus resistant organism doesn't use
all 64 triplet codons to make proteins
and doesn't contain the Machinery to
read the codons that have been deleted
from its genome and this cell provides
the starting point for genetically
encoded polymer synthesis
to realize genetically encoded polymer
synthesis in our virus resistant
organism we added synthetic DNA
containing the triplet codons we'd
removed from the Genome of the cell
an engineered translational Machinery to
read these codons and reassign them to
new chemical building blocks for new
polymers
this system can be programmed to make
diverse synthetic polymers by changing
the order of the triplet codons in the
synthetic DNA we can change the order of
the chemical building blocks that we
program into the resulting polymer
and by changing the identity of the
engineered translational Machinery that
we add to the cell we can change the
identity of the chemical building blocks
from which we compose the polymer
overall we've created a cellular Factory
that we can reliably and predictably
program to make synthetic polymers
using our approach we've already been
able to program cells to make new
molecules including molecules from an
important class of drugs known as
deptide macro Cycles
molecules in this class include
antibiotics immunosuppressives and
anti-tumor compounds
we've also been able to program cells to
make completely synthetic polymers
containing the chemical linkages found
in several classes of biodegradable
Plastics
as we build new polymer molecules using
our cellular factories
we have the opportunity to consider from
the beginning
how we might also use engineered
biological cells to break these polymers
down into the constituent chemical
building blocks that could be recycled
and used for new encoded polymers
we envision a circular bioeconomy in
which our new genetically encoded
Plastics and materials are manufactured
and ultimately broken down using low
energy cellular processes taking
advantage of existing bioreactors and
fermenters
by taking inspiration from nature
and reimagining what life can become
we have the opportunity to build the
sustainable industries of the future
thank you
[Applause]